the record-breaking winter storm will
take aim at millions of Americans as the
record-breaking cold wave intensifies
across the country at least 13 deaths
from the Midwest of the Northeast are
blamed on the frigid weather in Grand
Forks North Dakota wind chills could hit
minus 28 degrees today wind chills in
Chicago may dip to minus 7 and hit 15
below in Cleveland more than two thirds
of the country faces temperatures below
20 degrees this morning tonight Atlanta
could plunge to 19 degrees Duluth
Minnesota to minus 15 and we are also
tracking that major new system that will
bring heavy snow and strong wind up the
East Coast DeMarco Morgan is in Hamburg
New York where the wind chill is
expected to fall as low as minus 10
degrees today DeMarco good morning and
that is cold good morning to you take a
look at this outdoor deck right here
behind me you can see it's completely
covered in icicles and if that's not
enough to show you just how cold it is
look at this this is a big block of ice
it was once snow crazy right well the
cold water has also caused dangerous
conditions on the roads one person died
after a 75 vehicle crash on the New York
State Thruway dozens of vehicles were
stranded on the New York State Thruway
Tuesday as drivers battled whiteout
conditions you can't see gosh turn thing
in front of you everything was blurry
there was complete whiteout as
temperatures in Lancaster plummeted to
around 15 degrees the snowy roads turned
slick into the night authorities were
still cleaning up remnants of a massive
pileup and nearby Buffalo Niagara
Airport more whiteout conditions video
shows a plane barely visible while
trying to taxi Indianapolis Tuesday tied
a 131 year record low of minus 12
degrees we've had to relieve our units
much more quicker than normal in New
York City dozens of icicles formed on
powerlines and fire escapes as
firefighters battled flames and 13
degree temperatures
[Music]
will her Powell's car was parked in
front of the building and he came
outside to fight it frozen shut
I have never felt the cold like I'm
feeling it in these last few days only
thing I could think of is Alaska or the
Arctic it was actually warmer Tuesday in
Anchorage Alaska than in New York City
it is chilling it really stings the face
and in Chicago where it has been more
than a week since temperatures reached
at least 20 degrees you thought you were
cold last year you thought you were cold
last month but you weren't cold like now
you're called it is certainly cold right
now many of the schools throughout New
England but the Midwest and parts of the
south will be delayed or canceled today
because of the cold weather but it's not
over yet another winter blast headed our
way Jeff will swing things back to you
tomorrow thank you very much